[Music]
when you're a kid the world
all of it seems magical doesn't it not
all of it well yeah yeah i mean you
don't remember when everything was
magical yeah when you're a baby
everything probably seems magical yeah
exactly i don't remember being a baby
though one of my first childhood
memories was seeing darth vader on the
big screen i remember watching movies
that's magic yeah yeah i was thinking
that was magical but i just saw baby at
jersey mike's and the baby was like
looking at the sandwich fix at the same
toppings at jersey mike's are pretty
magical they're mad they're fun but like
i could it looked like the kid was like
in wonder it was like experiencing
wonder by looking at these and um and i
remember our nephew a couple weeks ago
we got him a magic eight ball you know
you'd ask it a question and he would ask
a question and like is it is it cold
outside and then
all signs point to yes or like are we
eating dinner soon and it's like outlook
not so good it's like i guess dinner's
still an hour away yeah so you'd have to
like finesse the truth a little bit it's
fun to trick kids is that what it is i
think so
because i was thinking like it also
feels like fun to have that kind of it
was a power that like they're amazed by
something like they're amazed by magic
it's fun maybe it's just fun to trick it
maybe well let's talk about it
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for short i am
your host the amazing justin
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is the what would
your uh magician name be
the
mediocre
christian
the quite unimpressive justin
um yeah it wouldn't be amazing the
amazing kresgen who else was amazing i
mean it's hard to really be amazing to
be amazed by something it takes a
certain kind of person to name
themselves the amazing something yeah
that's a whole lot i will never be that
kind of person even if i was amazing at
something i don't think i'd ever be the
kind of person to describe i know who
would reference that
reference your talent
right exactly that way because kresgen
what did he do he guessed people's he he
he was telling i don't know i don't know
for the record i don't believe that
magic 8 balls are magic i know but i
think most people knew that but we had a
struggle with our nephews i was there
that day and our father was trying to
convince him that it
wasn't magic
which there's something i understood why
you don't want to deceive a kid and you
want them to be able to think rationally
you want to like demystify exactly but
but we were trying to trick him yeah i
guess so but weirdly
our father is uh catholic is very um uh
has a lot of faith in the catholicism
and so there are elements of that faith
that are quite magical i think
well it depends how you use the word
magical i think
right i don't know if it's like magic
8-ball magical no or like our guest
today
type of magic yes well i guess yeah so
that's why we're talking about the magic
k-pop and and magic in general um
because our guest today
uh makes everyone believe in magic not
just little kids who are easy to trick
with a
toy filled with water what is that blue
substance is that just the uh is it it's
clear water but is it just like a blue
it just looks like windex yeah it might
just be windex
yeah maybe i don't think it's i don't
think the liquid is actually blue is it
i think it is i think the the little
thing itself
is white because when it pops up close
enough to the surface yeah you're right
it you can see that it's white you're
right you're white
um that was really stupid i i i hope we
can cut that out i mean we can cut it
out but it also might be fine
i hope we keep that in yeah my stupidity
justin long warts at all
it's an embarrassing war have you ever
had a wart i have yeah but you had one
on your foot right underneath my big toe
i remember there was a kid in
kindergarten who i really falls into the
category of who cares by the way yeah
maybe
uh there are a couple people there made
some like real shorties who might care
there's maybe some foot fetishes yeah
and actually foot fetishes wouldn't want
it oh right that's right that'd be a
doubt that would that's true i don't
think there are people who have
fetishized words maybe
but there was a kid i don't want to say
his name um
i'll call him uh
bjorn
uh because he was also a
but it wasn't bjorn uh in kindergarten
who it was a friend of mine and we there
was a part of the school day where we'd
have to hold hands i forget what it was
i think it was like the teacher was
introducing something and we'd all hold
the hands it was nice
and
i would always this
means i would always try to avoid being
next to bjorn because he had warts all
over his hand not because he was
scandinavian no no if anything that
would draw me to him
uh no but i and and the few times and
sometimes i could work on his hand yeah
his palm
ball in the back of his hand back front
all over you're sure there are warts
sports wow yes well anyway uh why have
we strayed so far off the magic path why
are we talking about uh magic and magic
8 balls well i know why
can i say yeah yeah i'm very excited to
say yeah but you don't often get to say
it
you can say it no no no i feel bad this
is the thing you do she didn't feel bad
i just thought because i don't want to
break the formula i know you like
formula it's a very exciting guest go
ahead david copperfield yes the david
copperfield he's the
the biggest i mean he's the a magician
of a lifetime he's one of the few
world famous magicians he's the only
living illusionist who has a star on the
hollywood walk of fame i mean say no
more right uh well we we should say a
little bit more because it's uh much
longer no no more that's it for the show
he's an icon he's a legend he's a living
legend he is he really is it was um
somebody i've been aware of since i was
a little kid he used to have those big
specials on t i mean i grew up we grew
up watching him and um
it was what a what a thrill he's like
our uh houdini right he is what an
accomplishment for somebody and and for
us for our little show to have the
modern day houdini well don't belittle
our show well i'm just saying it's an
accomplishment david copperfield is a
big guest for our show he's bigger than
the show he is definitely bigger than
this
um he might be bigger than every podcast
he's huge yes and so
uh we were so appreciative uh that he
came on of his time and so we're excited
for you to hear it uh he also has a
brand new book out called david
copperfield's history of magic oh it is
and who better to write that book with
that big of a title broad of a title
than david copperfield anyway we talk
about the book but mostly we talk about
what it's like to be david copperfield
he's one of those people i've always
just been curious like what is it like
to be you i'm so excited world let's
hear it okay here we go with the the
amazing safe to say
uh you can't say that very often amazing
sounds almost like an understatement he
amazes people for a living yes he is the
amazing david copperfield and he's our
guest right now on life is short life
could be a dream
[Music]
i just want to describe for people
listening if anyone's listening how
eclectic your background is
david it's amazing but physically the
background here or yes oh oh is that an
actual background or is it one of those
zoom no no no it's it's real who knows
with you
people must constantly be questioning
the reality when you're around
but where are you exactly
i'm in the opening section of my museum
oh wow it's uh
in fact it's where the book begins this
is the magic shop i recreated this magic
shop
um uh are we on by the way i think so
yeah believe it or not this is this is a
show oh okay
what is a show
you referenced the book it's it's uh
david copperfield's history of magic
it's you talk about 28 really
influential magicians throughout time
and uh well how did this start how did
your museum start i want to know
everything well this is the beginning of
my career actually this is a
magic shop that i recreated from my
childhood that is so cool yeah and the
brick and mortar magic shop is getting
less and less you know yeah less of that
happening which is in one case kind of
sad the internet is an amazing thing
it's got good points and bad points
right
but uh this is where kind of it began
for me magic shops were all over the
world and you know when i came into this
place it was called tannins in new york
you'd go up an elevator 13 floors
it wasn't labeled 13 because they
thought it was bad luck in those days
it would be like the 14th floor
isn't that people might not know that i
just recently learned this that in new
york the buildings is it i don't know if
it in every building but it's it goes
yeah 12 to 14 the floors
how strange yeah and they really uh
that's what it was but the uh the
building was an amazing place you'd go
up in the woo it was the wurlitzer
building in new york where they had
pianos in the front and you go up the
elevator and you walk out and you were
here and you felt like you were in
heaven
and it wasn't just magic stuff you'd see
johnny carson working on this side and
you'd see
orson welles practicing magic and you
see
god uh
even jj abrams has a ted talk
about
about uh going to tannins and this whole
ted talk is really about how his
storytelling and his was informed by his
uh
interest in magic as a youth
and uh so we recreated that shop in fact
jj came here
and you know everybody is very emotional
when they've
experienced this kind of thing to come
here and see this again it's really a
kind of a amazing thing but that started
me off really so what what are your
earliest memories of going there david
would you would you see those greats
that you mentioned would you see like
orson welles and um and would you have
interactions with those people yeah
literally yeah it was incredible you
know i'm a 10 year old kid you go what
my god muhammad ali would be over there
we've got teacher muhammad ali over
there
you know and so many people loved magic
that went on to do many different things
and
magic you know
really the idea of dreaming and the idea
of the impossible and discovering
discovering new ways of thinking really
informed a lot of art
across across the world who was the
first person
do you remember your formative
experience with that with being struck
by magic and the power of magic when you
were a kid do you remember the first
time you were dazzled by something
you know for me
uh like everybody i was searching for a
way to fit ins you know what can i do
with my world you know i swung the
baseball bat and you know the ball went
that way
david is referencing the out of bounds
sides
i'm referencing the fact that i sucked
yeah you know that sports
so
you know i said what am i going to do
and you know i started with
ventriloquism
you know throwing my voice uh-huh and i
was i was bad at that too
that led me that led me to magic and mad
with puppets then david you had a puppet
that you attempted to do it with
yeah i still have it and it's it's in
the actually in the museum yeah i was a
big fan of paul winchell you know that
name paul winchell yes he was the voice
of tigger
oh my god i loved him he does a lot of
great voices
yes look at him go that's right exactly
and that was you're just using
knucklehead which is one of his
characters
um yeah but uh him and jerry mahoney is
his puppet knucklehead smith and but i
loved it he was a brilliant brilliant
creator he created
the artificial heart for example he
invented the artificial heart uh he
invented the disposable razors you're
kidding yeah yeah but he was a great
voice guy and a ventriloquist an actor
amazing well i love this guy and i
wanted to be him but i couldn't be him
because i didn't have that skill but it
led me to magic which i got for some
reason i was good at and i was inventing
magic very very young
like how young david and were you doing
with like kids at school how did that
who were your first audiences it was at
school my family my friends and uh but
it came very easy to me i would go to
the magic or to the library in my local
library and i'd be this many magic books
on the shelf in the section david's
making it just like about a foot long so
there we're in a lot of very small
sections that's right um
yeah i gotta remember we're not well i
forget myself i know i know it's so
ideal yeah thank you for the reminder i
i think i really uh would take out the
magic book and i'd read the
the uh the effect what the audience
would see
but i wouldn't turn the page to real
them reveal the method i wouldn't learn
the method i try to guess the method
and try to
you know deduct what would will be the
technology behind it and i started
inventing new magic by doing that and
again i was bad at everything else but
magic for some reason i was good at and
when i was 12 i invented a piece of
magic that was in a very important magic
book called the tarbell course in magic
which was um
a whole series of books from the 1920s
that they kept upgrading throughout the
years and um yeah it was a big honor to
have a 12 year old 12 years old yeah
yeah
so what was the trick
it was called it was called mento pent
it was a mind reading trip with a pen
where the pen would allow you to read
people's minds oh wait i'm going to get
a pen
i'm going to see if
you need one of those that's a very
important part of this uh but um
i invented it in french class
because
my wife is french
ironically i learned no french so i
can't speak any french well you're too
busy with tricks uh yeah something like
that but but i i loved um this idea and
i it was the first introduction to to
my creation of magic this mento pen it's
it's okay it still kind of works they're
they're putting it out again as an
actual thing to buy but
but it's a lot of fun what's the idea
behind it david curie and how did it
come to you
i was in french class really bored um
and i was looking at this flare pen and
had a property about it that had kind of
a magic principle which i can't reveal
okay but that magic principle uh
said well i can make something out of
this that can amaze people with it and
it was a selection of
uh
a number between one and four and you'd
know
what the spectator chose and that was it
but um yeah
and i still don't speak french
even with a french wife she hasn't
taught you anything even angry words not
a french writer a french daughter crazy
oh
do they so your daughter must be
bilingual
getting there yeah wow and when she's
very upset with you does she say like
zutala i mean there are
certain i haven't heard that one but
okay well that's good that's a good sign
no but they they do speak a little
french together so i didn't learn enough
french to learn the secret talk oh
they can talk about you a little code
that's that's funny what david was was
the initially was it the
was it the effect that it would have on
people what was it the uh act of the the
reaction that these tricks these magic
tricks would have on people was that
part of the
the poll was that part of the i think
yes i think
we all do what kind of
uh gets us acceptance right yeah were
you funny as a kid are you funny
hilarious
uh i i think i think i cultivated that
because i was so tired i've talked about
this a lot i was i was very short very
tiny and um i kind of it was a way to
yeah like you said fit in and and be
seen
um and it was i loved comedy i loved
laurel and hardy and the marx brothers i
i just loved
making people laugh and so i i asked
because i do remember
um that having an effect on me you know
getting that kind of acceptance and
getting a reaction from people i think
there's a real important thing about
getting acceptance you know as a parent
now uh you know you kind of think back
to that time and how important
what how you react to your kids or react
to other people
what you give them the gift you give
them by your honest response to what
they're doing and for me you know
certainly when i got a positive response
because you know as kids you get a lot
of negative response right people like
really want to put you down sure it's
this is this before the intro though
yeah it's a juggle left there this is
before trolling on the internet yeah
they troll in person it was it was live
it was live action
and uh you know you had to find a way
around it or kind of accept it and deal
with it totally magic was my way and um
and if you're kind of good at it i mean
you're good at comedy and theater and so
forth i uh i was good at magic so yeah
that made me special yeah um
i think
there was a story you know
when i was 12 years old there was a
birthday party i think maybe 10 years
old it was a birthday party i did all my
magic stuff for all the kids at my
birthday party my own party yeah and uh
this is a horrible story but uh but i
can't wait yes it's really uh really
shocking um
it made me special i did all this stuff
my mother themed the party with little
uh
magician uh cutouts on the tables and
you know displays was all kind of themed
my mother's pretty crafty and i did my
little show and everybody applauded and
i put my all my stuff
the stuff that made me special into a
drawer in my room
and
10 minutes later my cousins without me
knowing went into the drawer
and pulled out all the stuff
saw how everything worked kind of was
dancing around them look we now have a
workstation like this
it was devastating
it was a really bad moment even the
cousins today
you know who's still in their 50s or
something they go we're really sorry
david
it was really horrible
and it's like because that's what made
me special yeah
oh my god you must have been it was
but it shows you how important uh you
know the things that you find that give
you value yeah you know yeah sure and
and you have to i learned from that
obviously there is a lock on all my
magic drawers now
all my beds
um but but when even the 12 the one you
you were talking about the referencing
that the pen one
those are secrets you don't want to give
up i mean that makes you yeah but you go
out of your way and then you work hard
to keep creating new things because you
know
today on the internet if you look up how
i do my stuff
there's a lot of revealed secrets and a
lot of those things is me
making making videos that are not real
to misguide people
so people come up to me and say i saw on
you know on the internet shows how you
do your thing yeah i know i did it it's
my kind of misdirection oh that's funny
so it's that's in its uh it's a magic
trick in and of itself is to
yeah distract from the actual magic
that's interesting
so but so that what must have been how
do you
how do you then recover from something
like how do you go back and regain
uh whatever it was about that that made
that felt special to you that separated
you it's it's um
you talk about the birthday party yeah
yeah well i think what i did was you
know you have sorrow for a while abject
sorrow
um then at the time i wasn't inventing
stuff so i you know i try to get my
parents to take me back to new york to
buy more stuff
but i think just
even today when i invent illusions and
people do the illusions people copy it
yeah there's a guy there's a guy in
france really popular guy in france
basically doing my show in vegas he
comes here he comes to the show and he
has a little uh he writes down
everything i say and do the music
choices all that and literally does a
show big broadway show in spain
exact it's my show oh
stories and so what do you do you just
keep going you know you i fortunately
have the ability to create new things so
you know
imagine if you know
somebody came to broadway with with vet
all the songs are west side story
and they claimed it as theirs
exactly it's a twist it's a twist yeah
it's just different enough um wow so do
you but then you think like i mean it is
a slippery slope because everything's
derivative i mean that is west side
story is derivative of romeo and juliet
you know the marx brothers begats
woody allen woody whatever uh but but to
copy precisely is a whole other level of
i mean that falls into some separate
category that would be very upsetting to
me if somebody came and just studied my
moves you know yeah yeah um and they
just see him there
are you i don't i don't know him but
people send me emails and all that stuff
and it's like it makes me sad but also
sort of after the sadness and the
frustration
it's very motivating too yeah
i'm a luckily able to write another song
you know metaphorically speaking yeah i
am ready to you find you find the the
motivation to keep going and that i
guess that helps the art well it must be
strange too because you struck me as a
very
obviously creative person and um
and so much of the joy in in doing it
for me anyway is is just in that is in
the process of doing it isn't creating
it so um i don't know how much joy i
would get from just um you know aping
another person's work but that's just me
i don't know maybe that the reaction
it's funny because magic the reaction is
so strong from the audience
it takes a lot of work to copy it it
does take work because you have to build
it and create you know right magic is
not like music
not like
you know we have to create the new piano
each time the technology as we create
each time uh so if i have a new idea for
things i can sometimes use something
that uh technology that existed but in
most cases the technology has to be
recreated new so for somebody to do that
takes work to copy what i'm doing yeah
but um
that's a close way of looking at it yeah
i mean it's it's it's not positive when
it happens yeah but
but uh it does you have to find the
kind of the the golden and the gold is
is is to keep going yeah yeah yeah who
are your heroes growing up who were the
guys that you
would put in your museum as being like
real inspirations well my magic
inspirations i'll talk about in a second
you know my story personal story is that
i was good at inventing magic and
performing it i people liked what i was
doing i found
a unique way of doing it because my
idols really weren't other magicians my
real idols were frank sinatra and fred
astaire and gene kelly victor fleming
the film director orson welles who i got
to meet and he hosted one of my specials
uh francis ford coppola uh people that
were storytellers uh with their music or
dancing or in the cinema people that did
that that really were the people i
looked up to
i knew enough about magic but those are
the people that formed my
you know who who i am and my magic
really reflected it my magic was about
storytelling yeah
it was about
doing things that
was
you know cinematic uh and uh and very
very different than other magicians now
that said in this museum and in this
book it's about the magicians
i also knew about them i was friendly
with a lot of them
um
and i've got rooms full of their amazing
things channing pollock was an
inspiration to me uh because of the
perfection of what he did he looked
great he became a film star for a while
and he was alive during my lifetime so i
got to meet him he was a guy that super
handsome produced dubs you can google
him channing pollock they called him the
most handsome man in the world and he's
a handsome name
chanting politicians are often handsome
yeah that's true right um he didn't have
the the body he didn't have a magic mic
thing going on but
he was a great looking guy and a very
skilled magician there was a guy named
ricciardi who was a
one of my
heroes not because he invented magic
because he didn't invent anything really
new magically um but the way he
performed it was amazing and um
his skill he was kind of a bullfighter
kind of guy and
was very powerful he was
gene kelly good as a performer you know
um
and where the other magicians were not
they had different
some were funny some were good and i
tried to get a little bit of all of that
in my career to try to to be somebody
that people liked hopefully you know i'm
still working on that part um he said
pretty well there and um and you know
and do things that were inventions that
were they could move the art forward
right um there was another guy named
robert
and hudan was called the father of
modern magic and he took magic off the
street
and dressed like
the sophisticated person and did a show
that of his inventions basically it was
automatons the first robots that existed
he invented um
[Music]
mystery clocks which are still used
today to tell time
with the hand that's just suspended hand
to tell actually tell the time really
remarkable and a very inspirational guy
um that
uh it you know pushed me forward to
invent more magic and to kind of
recreate what had been done before in a
new way and these are all detailed of
course in the book in history of magic
and and did you ever get to know ricky j
was he somebody that you were familiar
with this museum in fact
was
he was a steward of this museum for many
many years uh and uh eventually the
person that actually was the owner had
some
legal problems with with financial legal
problems so they had to sell it and they
sold it to me um and so i've been it's
become four times that size it was the
mulholland library
of conjuring arts uh back then john
mulholland worked for the cia was hired
by the cia as a magician to use magic
technology and magic principles to uh to
use an espionage and uh in stopping
crime and so forth so magic is has been
used in wars magic technique has been
used for different deception techniques
and uh
camouflage techniques that magician
would understand has been used in
wartime and in espionage and during the
cold war and mulholland was one of the
people that helped the cia did do that
kind of kind of thing
his library i should say yeah was
half of houdini's library was his
library houdini gave half of his library
to the library of congress and half of
his library to john mulholland
that mahon library i have so i have half
of houdini's library now oh my god and
the other half is in the
library uh of of congress so it's pretty
cool yeah that is really cool do you how
often do you so you're able to just
pull up houdini one of houdini's
personal books off the shelf many
thousands of them and wow we've
acquired many libraries around the world
in english library holland library and
combined them together to this amazing
amazing archive the uh i have 8 000
duplicate books
and duplicate books it's incredible so
this place is a kind of the smithsonian
of magic and all my friends
yeah it's it's an amazing thing and how
can people go there david what's that
like it's difficult because it's so many
secrets are here and everything is not
behind glass so what i do is i uh i do
exhibitions outside of the museum i'll
take exhibitions out of this and bring
it to new york bring it to la so people
can actually see things without hurting
uh the craft of what i do so you would
have to know you personally you'd have
to like make friends with you you'd have
to say come on somebody's podcast get to
know them a little bit in a public way
and then form a friendship
off the podcast get invited we do you're
totally welcome exactly but uh but we do
tours for scholars for the press we do
you know maybe 50
or
100 tours a year uh through here but
they're private tours that have been
taking the eight people at a time
through here and but i do try to share
it i do try to take exhibitions out of
here the book is the perfect way of
doing a tour okay museum so there's the
pitch this is a personal tour via the
the pages of the book but you'll see
pictures of it's an amazing amazing
place it is fascinating and and what i'm
seeing just a glimpse that i'm saying i
wish people could see this uh how
eclectic and uh
beautifully eclectic the background
looks here all the little like
tchotchkes and
that's what you call them
that you know make
gigantic things vanish and
and decapitate people and re make them
back again too they survive it you
know it's not like this language it's
the squid game you know there's actually
a happy ending yeah i haven't seen it
yet so thanks for the spoiler alert
[Music]
native deodorant is made with
ingredients you've heard of like coconut
oil oh that was christian getting his
native deodorant oh you have two ones
there oh yeah those are my favorites i
also like i found the lavender you know
oh the lavender is good this one i've
been really into lately the eucalyptus
mint but i'm telling you i'm really into
this lavender they're a bunch that are
they're they all work that's the crazy
thing about this oh they keep you
smelling fresh all day they they last
all day i've tried so many of these
natural i'm sure you have as well
making the switch to an aluminum free
deodorant it does not mean you have to
sacrifice on performance native will
keep you smile it does keeps you
smelling and feeling fresh all day long
besides their classic deodorant native
offers an unscented option
and a baking soda free formula for those
with sensitivities so if you want to try
cutting down on your plastic use
native even has a deodorant made of 100
paper board packaging amazing check out
the over 15 000 five star reviews from
happy customers who switch to native
you're going to love native as much as i
do i'm pretty confident in that right
now you can save 20
on your first purchase go to native
do dot com slash long or
use promo code long at checkout that's
native do deo yeah now if that wasn't
clear dot com slash long or use promo
code long at checkout to save 20
on your first purchase
are you having trouble sleeping i am
rather i was how did you alleviate that
trouble oh i'll tell you it's easy c
b
d plus cbd it's a daily use plus cbd
they're sleep gummies yeah and they help
you get rest so you can wake up feeling
focused and refreshed that's right i was
concerned that because you know
sometimes some sleep aids
can make you feel weird the next morning
a little bit
yeah not these these make you feel i you
saw me last night how calm did i see you
you did you seemed relieved and calm you
were having fun though still you weren't
like out of it are these formulated by
like amateurs and people who are just
getting into no no no quite the opposite
they're formulated by a team of medical
experts and doctors the plus cbd sleep
gummies taste great
delicious actually it's like a treat
before you go to bed and they're made
with award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark and lemon balm
which is i think your favorite kind of
bomb i love all bombs but that is my
favorite so sleep better tonight by
visiting plus cbd
oil.com and enter promo code long for 40
off your order that's code long at plus
cbd oil dot com
for 40 off
[Music]
people must think of you as how i do as
having this um because of your ability
to do this they must think of you as
having a
an almost like super human-like power
like a power that's all true it's all
true okay well that's what i was
wondering and uh thanks for being so
blunt and honest
uh i just agreed with you yes
but they do they must right i mean no i
can approach you differently i think
magic um
i'm so fortunate to get technology
before anybody else sees it i've got so
many friends that are futurists and uh
you know physics people and
and and scientists and i get to see the
stuff in the beginning
i get to incorporate that into my work
so there's so much technology and magic
and
i get to use it and historically you'll
see in the book
people who read minds you'll see how
they read minds and a lot of this is
technology that didn't exist that people
didn't know existed back then you know
imagine for example imagine a little
buddha
and inside was a speaker inside the
buddha and nobody knew
what a speaker was
so
you were going back to the 1920s speaker
existed but not commonly known
and
so you have a card selected nine of
diamonds
and
and the person who was on the other end
of the speaker would know it's night of
diamonds by
and you'd have the spectator remember
the nine of diamonds and the spectator
walk up to that buddha
and they said put your ear next to it
the buddha would say
people would freak out
i mean they just like they'd lose it
because sorcery is this
yeah so the point is that
you know that was technology that people
didn't know about and so this thing's in
my show currently that that uh five
years from now i won't be able to do
very sure
but i get to use it for now and in the
process of it actually i'm inventing and
with a wonderful team inventing new
technology that's going to be useful
someday i get to keep it for a while and
hold on to a title yeah but eventually
it'll get out there and and it'll be in
your home
uh robert hudan the name i mentioned
before
i think embedded the first smart home
in his home in the 1840s you know you'd
knock at the door and the door would
open mysteriously
with
electric electric principles and he'd
know how many people walk through the
door well now it's every grocery store
opens up the doors but that started as a
magic effect that was a piece of magic
um on conan i used to do a thing a
parody of me where a guy kind of with my
old my old haircut would like gesture a
door to open up or they would go up to a
garage and the garage would open up if
you'd make a thing like that but that's
it it was it was meant as a joke but it
was actually a real thing you know those
things were magic effects to start with
yeah and now they're well common i
wonder if you've seen neil befriend at
the show uh neil patrick harris's home
in new york have you been there the one
in harvard i've i've not big fan of his
he's such a talented guy oh he i'm
shocked that he hasn't like nerded out
on you i'm shocked that he hasn't
accosted you yeah
a long time ago he's welcome back it's
grown four times the size since oh wow
he was here yeah yeah oh i bet um well
he's in his home tell me what he has is
his home well similar i mean like you
were that you were describing to who
dan's who dan
a lot of little you know he's got hidden
doors and um there are tricks the house
is like kind of all like literally
tricked out uh and and has this kind of
gothic or maybe kind of more victorian
feel but he's it's it's the closest that
i've seen to what i'm looking at right
now but now you know but remember
imagine take that same stuff
and go a hundred years ago right oh my
god people must start religions you
could start religions with it it's like
people and some people did actually
yeah they take advantage of it yeah
i bet yeah well again people who aren't
familiar or don't consider that aspect
of it the
technological aspect they must be
um
really thrown by you they they must have
an odd reaction you must see a part of
just just i mean socially you must see a
part of human behavior that is unlike
what other people glimpse they i'm sure
often they may even be afraid of you do
you ever get stranger
i mean like really overwhelmed by you
and consider you
know if you look back at old magic
posters which plenty of them are in this
book by the way um
they're really beautiful incredible um
they're all very mysterious yeah and
kind of like you know i'm a sinister
there's a sinister element a little bit
or i'm smarter than you idea
i'm smarter than you which is you know
when you start getting reactions for
magic you kind of
uh
there isn't you have to think for a
second you know do i want to kind of
take advantage of this but i found you
know in my in my career i've always been
very welcoming i've always been part of
you know part of the people you know um
and uh i dress
not in costumes but i dress like a you
know everyone else dresses on the street
i think it makes them it makes the magic
stronger because i'm i'm relatable yeah
and i think you know all my stories are
not about the far east or or india or
the princess carnac it's all about you
know my girlfriend at the time you know
believing me or or or not i remember
them there being like a sexual element
too i mean i remember seeing them when i
was a kid so like pretty much everything
had a sexual element when you're a
certain age but like there was a very
there was a real like romanticism about
them and like uh of the time you know
the time of my work by the time it was
mtv right wasn't it it was all of that
so it was all about you know the
relationships and kind of and everybody
started doing that so i had to kind of
stop that now it's about family which is
more about where i'm at now so it became
from that very romantic very sensual
kind of
thing around it that story became more
about family and having kids and my [ __ ]
you know losing loved ones and all that
stuff uh or even childhood dreams you
know my show right now
is about um spaceships i make a
spaceship up here during my show you
know 50-foot spaceship you know over
their heads are dinosaurs trying you
know trying to change the language of
magic it's not card tricks for me it's
about dinosaurs and spaceships and time
travel and aliens all those things that
hadn't been uh part of my world so that
was where i had been going with it but
though it might seem
obviously it's much on a much bigger
scale and more fantastical does it still
incorporate the same elements of those
card tricks i don't want to call them
basic but the ones that
you know that people like i'm sure you
you mastered when you were younger and
ricky j of course was so good do they
still is it still those principles
you know
i've really made an effort to
invent new principles
i really tried to look forward because
uh for the art to move forward
there is
a kind of a willingness to keep doing
the same stuff with a new
wrapping around it or a new paint job on
the thing and for me that was very
unrewarding for me i bet yeah so the
method for uh
vanishing an airplane that i did a
million years ago you know that was a
new method that didn't exist or you know
or the
flying
thing that i used to fly around and
based on some old things but taken in a
very very different direction you know
so uh although it has roots in the
beginning
the actual piano has been rebuilt you
know so i'm i'm composing on different
on different uh
a different equipment and i think that
that that's and that's really that's
rewarding for me and you know you could
re-replicate and so many people in my
field
do do new versions of what's been done
before i really make an effort to to
have new principles that could uh
hopefully inspire people my business
down the line what do your kids think of
it uh david are they have you dazzled
them or or is it just like a thing that
dad does i think you know
obama said
something that made me very happy
i'm not sure it's his quote but he said
it anyway says you're never a prophet in
your own home
and that gives me a lot of strength
yeah my kids are great that mike i've
got great kids and they're you know they
have interest in
in theater and science and that stuff
and
not really great interest in what i'm
doing which is which is which is fine
and i'm not that person try to push
somebody in my business and you know
magic you know some of magic came from
circus and the circus world right um you
you knew you were going to do the
family's thing you know i'm friendly
with some of the the wallenda kids
and you know no kidding
yeah you know
they knew as a kid they're going to do
this no matter what and
certainly that wasn't my upbringing my
father wanted me i wanted to be an actor
and uh
you know so when i started doing magic
he was very supportive except it's kind
of living his dream in a way
yeah yeah yeah defeat us and he opened
the men's clothing store um to do
that gave up
it was new jersey mccordy's corby's
men's shop in mecca new jersey and then
warren new jersey but uh which we've
also recreated here
in my place so it kind of really tells
my story how cool i know i know what you
mean david because my mother was a
bearded woman and she wanted me to go
into that
field um
she's really disappointed
yeah mine i i can't grow facial hair
though um
what what so did your dad do that's
interesting that he wanted to be now
what what form did that take would he do
like community theater he did community
theater you know he out of the army um
the army air corps he uh was going to go
to
aada american academy of dramatic arts
because you can go there for free
but uh my mom said you gotta you gotta
eat so you know yeah she was she oh yeah
she she prioritized survival yeah um
what a buzzkill uh how often do you must
be sick of answering this but i'm
curious how often tricks go wrong how
often illusions go wrong or are they
something happens you have to redirect
the illusion yeah i have
multiple
endings to most everything i do
so if it goes in a bad direction i'm
usually able to give the audience an
experience that is satisfying
it's not satisfying for me because i
want them to see a certain thing yeah
but at least it gets me out of trouble
and it goes wrong a lot actually you
know yeah last night in the show
you know um there was a preset that
wasn't done quite right so the audience
saw kind of half half of an illusion it
wasn't so good
and um you know nothing to do with me
um
celine dion in her show if a lighting
queue is wrong they say she's a great
singer and did you notice lighting queue
uh yeah it's okay
i'm not sure or if uh barbra streisand
is on stage and a piece of scenery falls
they say the scenery fell but she was a
was it great
yeah with with me if something there's a
lighting queue wrong goes wrong
right to you and it goes yeah i'm a bad
magician so that is a man you know
having to be cute and funny and and and
you know personable knowing that
absolute terror is going to come behind
you is an interesting thing to deal with
every day
and you know you look at the world
differently i mean i bet i you know i
walk into a room i know where the exit
signs are i know i just i see you know
in school they used to put thumbtacks in
our chairs the kids would put thumbtacks
in the chairs so i'm trained to put my
hand in a seat before i sit down i'm
trying you know i'm trained given
awareness of awareness yeah we have a
program called the project magic which
is uh using magic in hospitals and it's
really great and when you're in
hospitals you meet a lot of patients
that have
you know been there because for for
cause they they they made a mistake and
one of the common mistakes in therapy is
an unsee unseat belted person who's had
a head trauma because of not having a
seat belt
well you see enough of that that what's
the first thing you do when you own a
car
man it goes boom it goes on it's
automatic it's like it's part of who you
are so all of that prep comes from a
little bit of fear a little bit i bet if
you're okay it's okay and you know i
just i that seep it goes on i look at
the seat before i sit down i go on stage
i look at all my presets to make sure
that the least amount of bad is going to
happen
it's really training as far as that i
once i once did uh the mike douglas show
remember mike douglas showing you that
kid uh no mike bullard i'm thinking
about okay mike douglas show is a very
very popular show from philadelphia and
everybody did the show i mean uh
they were they had co-hosts of the show
um uh john lennon was a host for a week
um i i you know i i was maybe 22. i
guess i had a bad week they put me as a
co-host for you believe it or not but
you know but john lennon was weak before
then david copperfield it was ridiculous
but on that show well what's wrong with
that i can see you hosting a show you're
great no i was the co-host but anyway
the point is that on the show that i was
on they had lucille ball and james james
stewart as what as yes yeah they had the
biggest guest like oh my god you so you
had to you interviewed them no no no
well kind of mike douglas did most of
the interview i was kind of i was the ed
mcmahon of the show that week anyway the
point is that is that ringabel ed
mcmahon yeah oh yeah but less pressure
to be at mcmahon
way less yes
yeah um and uh i've got a check for you
okay yeah exactly you just present
novelty checks that's right
so what happened was lucia ball on the
show
you know watched me do my little
performance that i did
and she said to me you know
we did so much physical comedy on i love
lucy that i would always she's talking
she would always set her own props david
always set your own props
and you know she had a gigantic dizzy
lou you know studio staff
but she set her own props because i get
it but to your question you know do
things wrong the answer is yes and what
do you do to to be safe about it you you
kind of go through all the plan b's
possible you know last night's show i
had no plan b we just kept going it was
the solution they already saw less of an
effect
but uh because there was no out for that
as an example but a lot of things i have
have ways you can't sweat you can't show
that you're sweating i mean you i swear
i swear you swear yeah yeah but see
that's the that's where the acting comes
into play i mean like you're that's how
you and your dad must have been so proud
of you for many things but like
specifically you had mentioned you know
his love of acting and that to me is
like how do you manage that anxiety
that's a performance that's pure
performance yeah was there a time where
you couldn't recover where it was just
um
it went off the rails and you had to
come up with something totally different
the only time the show stopped of note
is when i cut my finger off on stage oh
my god people thought it was an illusion
it's yeah it's a story that i've told
before but you know i was on stage doing
a
thing with a very sharp pair of scissors
and a a piece of rope and a woman on
stage and i would cut the rope and
restore it the whole sequence we did you
can see it on youtube
but one night i was not looking and i
cut the whole tip of my finger off
oh god and it was sitting on the tip my
finger was sitting on the blade of the
scissors and blood and blood was
everywhere
and nice my god and i said to the
audience
ladies and gentlemen i cut my finger off
and they started to applaud
of course of course the photo's part of
the show
oh my god and you know i don't like
blood all that much but they took me off
stage and they took me to the hospital
and they found mike tyson's cut man
no
his his plastic surgeon sewed my finger
back on
um same one who did his ear
uh i think he he's the one that did
somebody else's oh that's right evander
holyfield right right he did the bite
yeah so um no yeah so maybe he used that
same cut man i don't know how he feels
but
i got a great guy don't worry about it
wow that's
wild yeah so they sewed it back
they put the whole tip back on yeah do
you have any is there any residual like
weirdness about it no it's nice good job
wow yeah i can't tell i'm looking at all
your fingers there there's a god you
know this let's grow back that's a real
illusion i go heal heal you know
i called ernest angeli
well you know funny enough but david
people probably think
a lot of people probably think you have
those abilities but
obviously i don't claim i have any
abilities yeah all right because it's
all you know technique technology it's
it's it's invention it's it's all that
but you know there are parts of the
world that they think it's real you know
of course and i was um
before i went to russia
um
they were people picketing outside the
theater
from
religious groups because they thought i
was demonic or something like oh
my god yeah and you know and if you look
i'm smiling i'm kind of you know kind of
cute in the pictures and you know how
you possibly think them um
but um but they did
and they were going to shut us down
and
the church there i went to the kremlin
actually
to a dinner
the day before the show's opened
and um
gosh i'm going to get messed up the the
hats there looks like spades those big
tall religious hats would that be a
cardinal or what kind of
religious leader would that be um i
don't know in the in the russian
orthodox i don't know it must be like it
was it was a russian orthodox you're
correct
and the guy i walked into this dinner
and he was there kind of the leader of
the church
and he looks me over and i smile at him
and he gives me the thumbs up like this
wow
russian orthodox church means you were
going to hell
he was pointing up he was pointing his
thumb was up
um but um
but in that moment everything that all
the picketers went away and so forth
like no kidding yeah yeah it was worse
that was this way of saying i took care
of this
you're okay you're okay you're a nice
jewish boy it's okay
wow wow what does that feel like i i
know what it feels like to be you know
it was scary actually that was scary
i bet i bet people people that angry um
and and for for reasons that are you
know are
ridiculous but they believe it
nonetheless that must be really
wild wow i think you know yeah humanity
is interesting you know people are going
to believe certain things people are
going to be invested in an idea that
they have they feel very strongly about
that
and in magic that exists and i think you
know i do everything in my power to to
to show that it's a
form of inspiration of showing limitless
possibilities and not about anything
that's going to be
uh
something to be scared about yeah sure
um
david when you were researching this
book did you
uh i did i'm sure you learned a lot but
were there any like wild revelations
that you had um that really just amazed
you uh in
in so far as like the history of magic
100 there's
people have amazing stories you know
when i
took over the museum uh and then started
to make it grow
and multiply
you know in the beginning i didn't
really get it i was always looking
forward in magic i was i knew enough
about old magic principles but i was
always looking forward to inventing new
things
and when i acquired it i didn't
understand really why i was getting it i
didn't know have any historical
yearning for magic history but then i
started really looking to the stories of
these people and they all had the same
situations as me the same kind of
challenges uh there's
there's people in the museum that that
have done amazing things contributions
to society george melies who if you saw
the movie hugo wonderful scorsese movie
hugo is about melias uh who really
helped invent cinema storytelling cinema
you wouldn't have a job uh justin if if
you didn't if a magician well you would
have a job in live theater but the
movies were created by
uh
technology of making things appear uh
trains going or pastoral scenes
but it was a magician george melissa
decided to tell stories
yeah with that medium and to tell
cinderella or trip to the moon
and all those things started as a magic
effect in a magic show and uh the
storytellers adopted it because a
magician said we're going to tell
stories with this magic effect
of
of the cinema you know you know he the
trip to the moon uh the moon the the
rocket landing the the man and the
moon's face
seventy years later we landed on the
moon
seven years later and i really believe
that seeing things visualized
prototyping the future really helps us
make them real you know and so much in
my work in my show is about
you know redefining what humanity is
going to do in the future
and to try to dream big so that
smarter people than me will be in the
arts kids will be in there i'd say you
know maybe we could figure out a way of
making that happen for real
dinosaurs
cloning dinosaurs exactly it might
happen
thanks to you
you never know but no i think really we
talk about time travel and you know uh
and
and
and i'm you know i'm working with some
really amazing uh particle physicists
today i'm just amazing to really make
some of these things happen for real
and david how do you reach out to them i
mean are they i mean obviously they're
aware of you as a public figure a very
known person but how is it that you come
into contact with these people these
these innovators i do a lot of begging
okay
um it's a good magic trick and uh no i
think
they
understand
the fact that it starts with an idea it
starts with a dream yeah da vinci
um
drew a bunch of airplanes the
helicopters yeah
they didn't really work but they were
beautifully done and
the seed was there right it took 400
years from that da vinci
airplane idea to the wright brothers
yeah taking off for a few seconds 400
years so i think planting the seed is
very very important having those ideas
to plant a seed is very very valuable
and then time passes and finally we
figure out how to get it just right and
we're seeing it now imagine
we're taking spaceships and rockets and
landing them back on earth upright
is that that's a magic effect it's
incredible we're seeing that happen now
you know and uh
you know what we did with landing on the
moon
60 years ago uh you know now we're
starting to progress more we're starting
to get going again with this you know it
took a space race a competition with the
russians to get us to really get to that
right that really innovate yeah so so
does um having such a an intimate
understanding of this of how these
illusions work this this how to
incorporate this technology um into
these fantastical things that you do
has that made you um
more of a believer in the supernatural
in in uh hereafter let's say or in the
beyond or um or is it the opposite is it
is it you you are more beholden to the
practicality of life
you know it's interesting because i um
i should be a skeptic and most of my
friends in science are real skeptics
yeah you know skeptics even of
the flying saucers that we've been
seeing you know
yeah my my friends who are literally
genius geniuses are skeptical of that
you know um but there is many ways to
explain you know things that we see and
most of my science
associates are very skeptical i i'm a
very unusual person in the sense that i
i take great comfort in uh belief you
know belief in in god and kind of yeah
you know i take comfort and i kind of
like it uh and and um
so i kind of want to believe that and a
lot of you know that's very different
from the people who are uh in the in
this science and the
physics category uh of it but i do take
great
pleasure and you know uh oprah asked me
you know once on a episode uh do you
believe and you know
i have these on i've got have some
islands in the bahamas that that uh is a
resort that we put together and um
and
i have two cans there that uh reproduce
and you look at these little baby
toucans
and then an hour later they'll be
sprouts like straws that come out and an
hour later they'll be feathers
it's it's like really like
okay yeah it's it's evolution and
science and and uh and uh you can be
explained away but the way it happens is
really
you know quite breathtaking and quite
quite um
kind of supernatural and
ungodly and godly yeah right right right
well that was always my favorite
argument my there was an argument called
the teleological argument for the
existence of god which was which is
aquinas believed and a lot of these
great things really but it was it was an
argument by design it was the idea that
like the design the intricacy of the
universe is
could only have been created by
some higher power that it was
um just so beautifully put together you
know i
i think logically it's probably
problematic
but
personally i kind of
enjoy yeah the hope of it all you know i
i do enjoy it
um speaking of that uh
what is what would be a good time for me
to come to the islands uh and and stay
there for a little bit
we can get back to this
uh the islands that you have in the
caribbean tomorrow let's go okay great
um i think i've actually been near them
uh seen them um
uh how cool that must have been a dream
that must have been one of those moments
in your life where like i have an island
in the caribbean yeah
it's you know i saw it as an opportunity
for me an opportunity to create it's an
amazing palette to have
yeah you know i've actually have i hate
this sounds bad i have 11 islands a
little little islands
yeah so one i'm going to make a haunted
island right oh wow why not haunt an
island right uh one uh you know
one is going to be an island that's
going to be like beach blanket bingo you
know uh like the old uh frankie avalon
and that funny yeah yeah that might be a
that might be a potentially problematic
island i the haunted island you might
have an easier time with
um i'd like to go to both though yeah
exactly but it's it's called mushaki and
the islands of copperfield bay
and it's an amazing place it's like
it's a great place for me to create new
new things in a
non-theatrical but not in a non-theater
way so we do treasure hunts there that
are spectacular treasure hunts
we do james bond experiences there which
is great yeah
is this open to the is that near where
they shot that james bond movie is that
what am i thinking of the
actually no you're right there is
thunderball grotto in the bahamas yes
which is an amazing cave you can snorkel
to that's about i've been there i've
snorkeled there yet
we're 20 minutes south of there on a
boat
oh wow and it's a it's a place that
people take over uh one group at a time
family takes over it's not hotel rooms
you can rent um but you know it's a
place that a lot of famous people have
uh gone there for it's covert free
that's good it's a little bubble oh yeah
so that's that's a good thing uh how
cool yeah so so you're still working on
those i mean you're going to use those
as like that's like a future project
well no it's a place that people go to
and you know the the
sergey brin got married there on the
sandbar
uh
at the penelope cruise in javier bardem
got married there
uh but their whole group they take it
over 24 people at a time
but it's an opportunity for me to create
new things and right now yeah bad doing
all that it's fun i wanted to ask you
about the two cans do you raise the two
cans there i mean are they just part of
the island yeah yeah yeah yeah wow we
have tortoises aldabra tortoises oh my
god i love aldabratory
it's amazing you have aldabra tortoises
no it's not a competition i was lucky
enough to go to necker island and i
remember he had uh branson had aldabra
tortoises yeah yeah
wow yeah yeah
richard branson is fantastic he's great
and very inspirational to me you know i
love everything he does and you know our
version our island is is similar in in
many ways because it's a takeover island
yeah yeah but it's also
what i've done is i i put what i do
in my place is very theatrical and i've
got houdini's pool table in the game
room
oh my god and
we have uh our gym is the jack johnson
gym based and the uh amazing fighter
from the turn of the century and
we've made everything has a real soul to
it it's uh my unique take on that hole
have you finished the haunted island yet
no still working on it still working oh
boy that have fun how cool um did
houdini died from getting hit in the
stomach is that an uh urban legend
that's right that's correct it is true
huh yeah yeah he got hit in the stomach
uh when he wasn't ready and uh
a kind of appendicitis began and uh he
died on halloween which is pretty good
promotion right pretty good yeah for
halloween too
[Music]
[Music]
hey life is short listeners i want you
to imagine that you're on a warship in
the final days of world war ii you're
excited to go back home looks like the
war is ending you've just delivered the
necessary parts for the atom bomb
but then disaster strikes your ship is
struck by enemy torpedoes and within
minutes you're floating in the ocean
fighting for survival from wondering
against the odds is an immersive podcast
that puts you in the shoes of resilient
people surviving harrowing ordeals in
their new season you'll hear about the
infamous sinking of uss indianapolis and
the survivors fight to stay alive it's a
fascinating story you probably know the
story of the uss indianapolis from the
famous scene in jaws that robert shaw
recounts um it is harrowing to say the
least the sailors who survived the
attack were stranded in the open ocean
for
uh five days i believe they endured
brutal weather
rough seas dehydration salt water
poisoning hallucinations and it was one
of the deadliest shark attacks in
history
against the odds has the harrowing true
story of how the brave men of the
indianapolis survive the worst disaster
at sea in u.s naval history listen to
against the odds on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen a week
early and add free by joining wondering
plus in the wondery app hey life is
short listeners wonder ease even the
rich podcast is doing a two-part series
on the bizarre and fascinating
kidnapping of paddy hurst and you won't
want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patty hearst who happened to be
the heir to the hearst newspaper fortune
was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity and a completely unexpected
twist patty announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patty was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
thumbs up
yeah by far far the classic uh if you
could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play and why mm-hmm
boy the lightning is slowing down
well you had mentioned you weren't let
me think
what would it be i think i'd like to be
a great swimmer okay yeah
snack food what's your favorite snack
food snap pea crisps
oh great promotion for them yes i love
those a movie that you loved growing up
one of your favorite movies growing up
that you wanted to introduce to your
kids well i did a lot and i forced them
to watch all these movies i uh
it's uh it's easy wizard of oz
obviously uh gone with the wind although
it's pretty problematic today same
director victor fleming a big fan harold
and maude
what and the producers love the
producers i have the actual script from
the producers where it says springtime
for hitler and they crossed out hitler
and they wrote mel brooks wrote the
producers because they couldn't use the
title springtime for hitler oh my god
that's so which is great yeah i have um
uh
and and of course you must have loved
movies growing up it still informed
informs what i do and of course the best
movie of all time which is step brothers
oh yes oh my god oh my god i love that
did we just become best friends
yeah
yeah
but uh
it's so funny that you know you watch
uh joaquin phoenix
you know he does he does the joker right
gigantic success with a joker and they
ask him what's your what movie you see
more than anything else he says step
brothers
isn't that funny yeah i know i remember
uh sean penn cornering vince vaughn and
telling him how much he loved wedding
crashers he thought wedding crashers
should have won
the oscar and you know it's funny when
these serious actors um i love it
yeah yeah uh your go-to karaoke song oh
it's a it would be um sinatra
and it's not your dean martin you're
nobody if
uh you know until somebody loves you
um yeah yeah yeah or or i'm sorry i'm
sorry
uh taxi
taxi
yeah okay yeah
uh and and i'm curious because you said
you you had time with orson welles what
that he was he was uh
sounded like almost a mentor to you what
was he like
he's such a fascinating character well i
got to know him pretty well he hosted my
first tv special
wow uh and uh he wanted to be known as a
magician and he was a very good he
actually was a very good magician if you
watch the old
videos from doing stuff
terrific um we have it playing the
museum i have some of his props in the
museum
and
he's a chapter in the book uh in a
special edition that uh barnes noble has
but um he was a very very
inspirational guy you know and uh
i um
yeah i mean citizen kane you know yeah
just you watch you just go wow you know
every single thing it just shows oh man
exactly and all of the stuff that that
you know as a young people that just
have a bunch of people with unlimited
budget
ish for that time just creating
something really really great i would
have loved to have watched that take
place
greg tolan the cinematographer greg
toland
you know i have a movie that he made
uh a magic movie that he made little 10
minute thing that greg tolan was a
cinematographer on i used used at my
show for a while where i would interact
with a young orson wells
on a film talking back and forth to the
screen you can watch it on the flying my
flying special uh and it's great greg
tolen is the cinematographer and um
uh yeah he had a big big impact and you
know i would love to be a film director
of that that
level you know yeah yeah and he wanted
to be a magician you know really and he
was actually a pretty good magician well
david had you have you considered i know
there's so much film work that goes into
your work and cinematography of course
and but have you ever thought about
directing like a narrative making a
narrative film you seem like you have a
real love for it yeah
it's never too late you know never too
late yeah but i think you know i i was
the director of all my specials my tv
specials yeah and um and uh they got you
know a lot of emmy awards um from there
21 i think you know yeah
um but uh but that was very very very
flattering so you do you know when you
try to focus and do really good work as
good as you could possibly do it's nice
when people you know kind of pay
attention to it but oh god you know i
would like i would love to have
it in me too to direct the film some
some like comedy that people don't
expect like a step brothers um who was
who was your very first celebrity crush
um it would have to be annette funicello
oh okay beach blanket bingo yeah yeah
but before that this is a mickey mouse
and then yes
so you know
and
i was
four five and you know she was on tv and
and uh yeah it was
for sure that
uh if you had to get a tattoo david well
i told my kids if they get a tattoo
there's no money in the future for them
so
okay just for my kids everybody else can
get beautiful tattoos and that's been
seen really
there's people that actually have
tattoos of me yeah is there any justin
long tattooed people i can't believe i'm
saying this but i've seen it yes there
there are some real horror i did a
couple horror movies that people love
and so there are horror my chara there's
a character that i
i died at the end of one called jeepers
creepers and my eyes are removed it's
really gruesome
and i've seen that tattoo people have
that and it's what do you think i mean
i've had it many times
it is uh
it's both flattering and disturbing it's
like a weird mix of those two what's
disturbing about it what's disturbing uh
that somebody would have me to go to
those lengths would would it would um
certainly to have my dead image on them
like a dead me
so you know i did a horror movie too you
know not quite as good as yours yours
was better i did a movie called terra
train with jamie lee curtis in it oh and
i'm really bad in it don't watch it i
tried okay now i want to see it uh don't
is it that bad it's beautifully shot
john alcock who uh
did the barry lyndon and then oh wow and
and the shining yeah the great
cinematographer he did he did the movie
and roger sparta
who turned out to be an excellent
director uh did there was his first
movie the territory so i really suck in
it but this really pretty shots of me
they made me look kind of pretty in it
um
but which is the hard work um but alcott
was up to the challenge um but i did um
this movie and i get killed in it too
spoiler alert i don't care don't watch
it i get killed um you know really
mortified um yeah gruesome and luckily
they haven't tattooed me in that
you know that condition of it
but you must be tattooed a you as a
magician you must have seen
a lot lots isn't it funny
me tattooed and it's the same reaction
exactly your impression of it you know
the flatteries you know it kind of focus
on the flattery but it's like
really you made that decision
i know forever also signatures they do
that with you yes yes you sign my arm
and this arm gets the signature gets
tattooed but there's so much pressure on
that i found a tremendous amount of
pressure
uh what if i mess up this is going to be
permanent this is it
what if i do something that they they
don't like me anymore yeah i know well
uh you're stuck yeah um
how funny how funny david
what is your favorite fruit uh
probably uh is watermelon a fruit yeah
oh god yeah watermelon and pineapple
though you know kind of in there
really good for you too um uh and who
would you like to play you in your
biopic the handsomest guy
ever let's see i want okay let's see
that would be tom brady not bad you know
okay
to get some acting lessons you know you
know andrew garfield andrew garfield
could play you i better yeah which
whichever and he's terrific right that
wouldn't be bad a great actor uh you'd
have to teach him a lot
of illusions um who was your favorite
muppet i'm sure you've worked with the
muppets you know when i was a kid
a friend of mine uh
his name was alan bersky brought me to
see the muppets
uh
i went to see him as a kid i walked into
haha h.a henson associates we walked
this thing yeah and there was the big
like i think maybe snuffleupagus this
giant human bigger than human size thing
in the walking up the stairs to see
these things like
really just one of these enormous
characters i think would have been my my
favorite thing
yeah yeah cool yeah uh makes sense and
and a beatles song a beatles song that
you love that you'd love to hear right
now if you write up go to the jukebox
there's a lot of them you know that's
hard one yesterday
norwegian wood i love that song i once
had a girl or should i say she once said
me
oh god yeah and um your favorite pizza
topping david i think pepperoni yes yes
old-fashioned great it's a thumbs up um
thin crust
yeah okay okay this was such a thrill
for me you got to come to las vegas come
to the museum i'd love to share with you
for those of you who can't do that one
of the great hanukkah christmas gifts is
this book it's an amazing beautiful
coffee table book very affordable and
i'm really proud of it thank you and i'd
love to see you in vegas i am a huge fan
i was this is such a thrill thank you
thank you bye-bye
[Music]
so so that just happened
yeah there's a little bit of um there's
a slight new york i hear a little i mean
even though he grew up in new jersey
it's jersey it's a little like
like yeah jersey like piscopo a little
bit like uh yeah and also a little bit
like new york jewish um just yeah the
hint of that very surprising that he's
jewish no not surprising that he's
jewish but surprising that he is as
accessible i
know as he is i was very very pleasantly
surprised by that you don't both have to
be surprised that david copperfield
should be so down to earth and
accessible
i know because you think of him as oh
yeah he's this icon but also like what
he does the the reason he's nikon is
he's got this show i mean he's like
actually hellman he's like you know such
a performer and and those those specials
that he used to have they were so um
like larger than life i guess
and he had such um
and a mysterious persona and he was just
uh just did not seem like somebody you
could like have an easy fun conversation
right i think i'm a victim of
uh thinking of him too much
by what he does i'm sure there's a lot
of people so because of that because i
think of him as this guy who can do
magic on that level i think of him as
being like as a person i know mysterious
i know well that's what i was trying to
get kind of like aloof and weird yeah
but he was like very down to earth and
cool and funny and forthcoming about how
practical a lot of what he does is i
mean all of what he does is it's just uh
it's so much of a science science and
it's yeah he the incorporation of
innovation and
technology was that to me was um
how forthcoming he was about that was it
was interesting we were talking about
the match gate ball earlier there's
something about
magic in general that it's it's
inherently strange the whole field
because
it's not magic yeah but it's called
magic right and david copperfield is
called a magician
but the truth is
he has access to these secrets like
brilliant things he's created obviously
like i do not mean to diminish it by any
means but
it
it is a trick well you know the whole
thing is a series of tricks which makes
sense that a lot of those great
magicians he talked about
in his book as well history of magic um
that would would be real innovators
would be have invented uh that guy
mulholland invented things that were
very like
common
place now they're very like practical
right because to present a trick too
it's
have you ever met magicians as a kid who
are kind of like strange
seeming and like not so smooth socially
but they just knew how to do with
certain cards yeah it's like they'd
spend a lot of time indoors like
learning right but they so the trick
itself was impressive but the
presentation wasn't necessarily yes he
seems like i mean there's a reason he's
who he is is that his presentation
oh i know he's incredible like i mean
he's such a good
talker and he's very charming very
charming yeah i can see him
just putting on this one-man show he has
that one-man show kind of energy and the
the looks i mean part of it is like a
superficial thing but he's like he's
handsome and he's got this um presence
he's got a real presence and like i
remember when we were kids thinking of
him as like
being kind of like a romantic figure you
know that he was like they're always
like women around at his shows and he
was like
wooing them and stuff in the in the
shows i mean there was something there
was like a romantic element he was like
sexual yeah
i think he said sensual that his show
had incorporated like a sensual element
but it does it's like yeah i can see
that yeah and like he wore these kind of
like um he has yeah i mean you know i
know i want to hear you describe it i
just kind of
failed out well here's what i mean by
sensual
yeah but he then he would reference he
had like a very very slight i don't know
if his insecurity but he kept
referencing that he wasn't like handsome
or or he wanted someone handsome to play
him or
um he had a few moments where i was like
what is he talking about he's so
handsome like he yeah he's like famously
happy he is right he hated um famous
models claudia's [ __ ] potty shiffer
right and i never thought of him as
being like well how did he get yeah yeah
you know
it was like they were sort of like
matched
you know there are and i don't know
everything that david and claudius shift
for our match physically
but it's true it's like oh that makes
sense instead of like
whereas like there were other couples
and i don't want to i'm sure people
thought that of me you know so i
shouldn't say but like oh people have
definitely thought
no offense i think the majority probably
think how did he your own family
yeah i think that of me i don't get how
that guy can just steal his act i don't
i know why does he get that why doesn't
he i would i'd sue him or sue him i know
it's that must be outrageous there's
probably a reason he hasn't so i i
didn't want to be negative about it but
um
or be too like litigious sounding yeah
like you should aware i know but like
truly like that's [ __ ]
crazy crazy he's like hurt by it yeah i
think really affected by it well he
brought it up and he he
i think that's when he related that to
the story when he was a kid and yes
people stole his yes that was a
formative experience for him and it
still is something that i'm scared of
that must really trigger i wonder if he
has trust issues in life in general i
should have asked him that yeah well get
him on the show
but i wonder if he holds other like
non-magic secrets other secrets
close to the vest right i wonder
right maybe i mean he must have some
like how do you ask somebody that
probably well it's the point where he
well now you're friends with him you
could ask him
yeah um i don't know if you would trust
me if he hears this we shouldn't be
talking about it i i want to like i want
you want to preserve the new friendship
yeah
there's something fascinating though
about like holding on to those secrets
and and having to
um
kind of throw people off the scent like
i know how he makes those videos that's
so wild to i know like prevent people
from figuring out the actual secrets and
then this everybody goes through all
that
so this little like um
doppelganger that he has
it's not fair to call him a doppelganger
doppelganger's people that just like
look like somebody naturally he's just a
spanish he's a spanish thief
i'm in his country of origin now
standing he happens to be he's from
spain
let's call him diego copperfield i
wonder what his name wonders his stage
name is i wonder is it copper field and
because those are english words that
mean other things could you say is it
spanish is there a spanish well now that
you know spanish you should be able to
translate copper and field right um why
are you looking down on your phone well
sorry i was gonna translate it i know
i'm just kidding i thought you should
just know that by now um field i don't
know that one
copper i don't know that those are
those are obscure copper is obscure
field i should probably know anyway uh
diego copperfield
i i wonder like you know if i were david
copperfield i would go to diego
copperfield show and just go in the
[ __ ]
heckle him heckle the [ __ ] out of him
that would be a justifiable heckling oh
yeah it's like oh where'd i see that
before oh right i created oh yeah or
just yell out what's gonna happen i know
how you did it
but he doesn't want people to know the
secrets if you couldn't do that true
it's a tricky position to be in
literally let's read a letter is that
your chair no no i'm not moving
okay this is from amy cher
so i'm going to share it with you share
spelled like cher yeah no no like do you
mean the singer no like i'm just going
to share this with you this spell cool
or
it could be charai
subject our intimate relationship
unbeknownst to you
dear justin and christian i've put off
writing this email since your first
episode with dax first i will just
clarify that i am female okay she knows
that wouldn't be that's funny
and that's funny and take that stress
off you right there now we can focus
it's funny she knows us i've always
loved anything justin has been in
beginning with ed thank you amy you are
one of the actors that i would see
anything just because you're in it it's
really nice like buying a weird al album
and not knowing any of the original
songs
but that's not the point a few years ago
i was dating someone who i very much
considered my person and he died
oh boy
he was in his 40s and it was not
expected
through our relationship pretty much
anything we did had a soundtrack and so
listening to music ended up becoming
very difficult for me oh my god
i bet
as a result i discovered podcasts and
shortly after i did you released this
one so putting together an actor i
adored with the concept i was really
embracing life really is short so yolo
[ __ ] sorry i'm in my 40s and still
clinging onto that
was a no-brainer
wow yeah
i bet both justin and christian have
made my runs cleaning cooking and
ignoring my children so much more
pleasant and i just wanted to say thanks
i love everything about the show and
you've both done a lot for me oh man
what a beautiful letter yeah my god
um
truly thank you um the only thing back
to amy the only thing that is nagged at
me that was brought up on the show a few
times though a long time ago so maybe i
should let it go is the fact that at
least justin has not been to montreal
not sure about christian
yes i know that's been nagging me too
and it's been coming up lately everyone
i know has been and loves it i've been
it's there you go i love it there you go
but i i'd like to go again because i
haven't been since i was in college
oh man college was a long time ago yeah
i'd really like to go again yeah but i
remember having a great time there i i
and it's so close to me i mean it's
there's really no i have no excuse you
you would like it a lot i i bet um
because i love i've been spending time
in europe you can start learning french
on duolingo okay
okay
god i've almost given up on you yeah i
haven't done it whatever who cares
before you give up completely you should
learn how to say copperfield yeah that's
spanish oh why don't i look it up
it could wait till after the show we're
still on the show i forgot okay back to
amy based on your love of austin in new
orleans i can't emphasize enough how
great my city is outside of winter
you have both done so much for me let me
bring this back to your attention and
just yolo your butts to montreal you
won't regret it i i'm going to
i am going to uh and yolo is um yeah i
never really said it out loud a lot but
it's a great expression
uh you only live once
i mean it's it's
it's great and true yeah well
both maybe not true but uh that's true
yeah maybe we'll be you'll be
reincarnated as a what's that kind of
turtle that you like that um is on
copperfields island oh aldabrain
tortoise yeah maybe it'll be
reincarnated as an aldabra tortoise
they're similar to i think they're found
i think the aldabra islands i think
they're near the say shelley's or maybe
it's the same you're looking at me for
help okay sorry i can't help you but but
my point is they're um they're related
to the galapagos tortoise because the
continental shift happened those two
little islands drifted apart cool and uh
that's why they're both that's another
place you'd like to go yes yeah that's
number one galapagos that's top on the
list i'd love to go to
the seychelles too seychelles is that
how you say it i don't know anyway a lot
of great wildlife there unique to that
island anyway um
thank you back to amy thanks again you
guys you are both wonderful amy oh thank
you amy what a nice letter uh uh would
you rather for my kids
best kind would you rather always need
to pee or always need to fart great
question
always need to always need to does that
mean you can't you can't i don't quite
let's let's let's say that
let's say it's just the feeling of
having to do it you always have to do it
needing to pee can hurt a lot more
needing to both will keep you up at
night
um both are uncomfortable but i think he
is more uncomfortable oh i don't think
having to fart would keep me up oh it's
kept me up really yeah it would you
think fart yeah you got stuff going on
in your body
you've never been kept awake from like a
like a
pinballing fart maybe kept me awake a
little bit but i'm i guess what i'm
saying is i could sleep with a fart in
my belly and i can't sleep if i have to
pee
that's a hell of a quote um
that should go in roger's
you know you know what i'm saying though
yeah like if i really have to pee
there's no way i'm falling asleep that's
true i think you know why you know i bet
it is because we have
this built-in fear
of wetting the bed yeah that's true so
i think because i ha at least i do i
don't speak for everybody but i think i
have that fear because i used to wet the
bed when i was a kid
um so i i'm so afraid of doing it
because it was such an awful feeling
when you did do it yeah
shame that um
i can't let myself relax enough to fall
asleep if i have to pee oh i suspect
that's part of it well wouldn't but i
have no fart shame but wouldn't it be
[ __ ] the bed i mean what if i've
never [ __ ] the bed
so maybe that's so proud if i had
that should be the name of my memoir
yeah i've never i've never [ __ ] the bed
the christian long story well assuming
that it continues to be true i'm sure
eventually i will shoot the bet
but i've i've um i've never shut the bed
so i don't have that fear so having a
gas bubble in me doesn't give me that
inability to relax i bet that's part of
it maybe it would i see i just think it
hurts more to hold in p it that too
that's why in general to answer this
question it's a good question yeah i
would rather have to fart than th that
feeling the need to fart the need to
fart yeah both are so satisfying now
that i think about they're so satisfying
when you can relieve it they both would
be very frustrated i would rather
relieve the p than the fart
i think
you know when you have to go so badly
that there's like a a shutter of delight
when you're doing it it's the piss
shiver piss shiver
don't you ever get that like a full body
like so i'm saying yeah yeah whole body
yeah
it's like it's kind of like parting
you don't get that with most things
you get that with certain things but
it's very rare
hmm yeah i just wonder what if other
people know about the piss chiva what if
david copperfield's listening to this i
bet he's had piss shivers
yeah and i don't know if women get it it
might just be a my own thing no it's
just a physiological thing oh really i
think so i think i've heard women do get
it really
yeah ladies shorties
they didn't
i'm curious about that if women get
pissed shivers because i don't know if
every guy gets it either i know it's
something that i've always gotten oh but
especially when you have to go for a
long time and you finally go road trip p
oh man sometimes it's like an
uncontrollable bodily yeah
yeah
oh man i just keep picturing david
copperfield listening to this i think
he'd be into it yeah he's just so step
down to earth
i'm imagining that the pre-interview
david copperfield right one that i have
in my head yeah i am you gotta shake
that loose like because now you know
like the p finally coming out of your
urethra
well i think we've finally jumped the
shark
we have um
we've we [ __ ] the bed so to speak yeah i
don't think so this is a good episode
you think i think so um think i mean i
think amy really saved the episode
because that letter was incredible it
was and heart felt like she shared it
with us yeah i mean she's probably sick
of that kind of joke and i'm i'm so glad
she wrote in i you know i'm really glad
she wrote in and
i hope more people continue to write in
and if they want to write in
it's life is short at wondry.com you
have a lot of uh desires hopes
i do
and let's let's also i like when people
write in i know it's great i love
reading those letters i wish we could
read more than one letter i know because
yeah but then the show would be too long
um so hopefully it was just the right
amount of time the show for all of you
and hopefully uh maybe even left you
wanting more
more talk about peace shivers
and [ __ ] the bed
uh we're we're so happy you listened and
you joined us and we are so grateful to
the
master illusionist and now i dare say
my new friend you should all get his
book
it is called david copperfield's history
of magic yes and um do not go see
the fake david copperfield see the real
one yeah don't support some like
criminal it's an imposter
faker what's the word for imposter in
spanish um
okay we're gonna go because justin has
to go do spanish lessons and uh we'll
talk to you next week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian log also produced by megan v
monaco and katie v allen and senior
producer on this one is michelle miesha
lans audio engineer audio what engineer
sergio enriquez sure is executive
producer marshall louie yeah and for a
company that is
[Music]
wondering funny funny idea for a short
mission possible
um to set to the theme song of mission
impossible but uh
pending the rights
but uh someone's got to do something
that's quite easy
and it's all to the time
and they have to like they have the key
and they have to get into something and
it's very easy mission possible
short film
you